how much of the malleability is
hardware how much software is that
useful on the brain
so like what what are we talking about
so there's like
there's neurons there's uh synapses
and the all kinds of different synapses
and there's chemical communication like
electrical signals and there's
chemical communication from this in the
synapses
uh what i would say
the software would be the timing and the
nature of the electrical signals i guess
and the hardware will be the actual
synapses so here's the thing this is why
really if we can i want to get away from
the hardware and software
metaphor because what happens is as
activity passes through the system
it changes things now the thing that uh
computer engineers are really used to
thinking about is
is synapses where two neurons connect of
course each neuron connects with ten
thousands of its neighbors but
at a point where they connect um what
we're all used to thinking about is the
changing of the strength of that
connection
the the synaptic weight um but in fact
everything is changing the receptor
distribution inside that
neuron so that you're more or less
sensitive to the neurotransmitter
than the structure of the neuron itself
and what's happening there
all the way down to biochemical cascades
inside the cell all the way down to the
nucleus
and for example the epigenome which is
the
um you know these little proteins that
are attached to the dna that
cause conformational changes that cause
more genes to be
expressed or repressed all of these
things are plastic
the reason that most people only talk
about the synaptic
weights is because that's really all we
can measure well
and all this other stuff is really
really hard to see with our current
technology so essentially that just gets
ignored
but but in fact the system is plastic at
all these different levels
and my
my way of thinking about this is
an analogy to paste layers so pace
layers is a concept that stuart brand
suggested about how to think about
cities so you have
fashion which changes rapidly in cities
you have
um governance which changes more slowly
the structure the buildings of a city
which changes more slowly all the way
down to
to nature you've got all these different
layers of things that are changing at
different paces at different speeds
i've taken that idea and mapped it onto
the brain which is to say you have some
biochemical cascades that are just
changing really rapidly when something
happens
all the way down to things that are more
and more cemented in there
and this is actually uh this actually
allows us to understand a lot about
particular kinds of things that happen
for example one of the oldest
probably the oldest rule in neurology is
called ribose law
which is that older memories are more
stable than newer memories
so when you get old and demented
you'll be able to remember things from
your your young life maybe you'll
remember this podcast but you won't
remember what you did
a month ago or a year ago and this is a
very weird structure right
no other system works this way where
older memories are more stable than than
newer members
um but it's because
through time things get more and more
cemented into deeper layers of the
system
and um and so this is i think the way we
have to think about the brain
not as okay you've got neurons you've
got synaptic weights and that's it
so yeah so the idea of live wear and
live wired
is it is it it's it's like a it's a
gradual
yeah it's a gradual spectrum between
software and hardware and so
the metaphors completely doesn't make
sense because like when you talk about
software and hardware
it's really hard lines i mean
of course software
is uh unlike hardware but even hardware
but like
so there's two groups but in the
software world there's levels of
abstractions right there's the
operating system there's machine code
and then it gets higher higher levels
but somehow that's actually
fundamentally different than
the layers of abstractions in the
hardware but in the brain it's all like
the same
i love the city the city metaphor i mean
yeah it's kind of mind-blowing because
it it's hard to know what to uh
think about that like if i were to ask
the question
uh this is important question for
machine learning is
how does the brain learn so
essentially you're saying that
i mean it just learns on all of these
different levels at all different
paces exactly right and as a result what
happens is
as you practice something you get good
at something
you're physically changing the circuitry
you're you're adapting your brain
around the thing that is relevant to you
so let's say you take up
um do you know how to surf no okay great
so let's say you take up surfing
yeah now at this age um what happens is
you know you'll be terrible at first you
know how to operate your body you know
how to read the waves things like that
and through time you get better and
better what you're doing is you're
burning that into the actual circuitry
of your brain you're of course
conscious when you're first doing it
you're thinking about okay where am i
doing what's my body weight
um but eventually when you become a pro
at it you are not conscious of it at all
in fact you can't even unpack what
it is that you did think about riding a
bicycle you you can't describe
how you're doing you're just doing it
you're changing your balance when you
come you know you do this to go to a
stop and so
so um this is what we're constantly
doing is
actually shaping our own circuitry based
on what is relevant for us survival of
course being the
the top thing that's relevant but
interestingly especially with humans
we have these particular goals in our
lives computer science neuroscience
whatever
and so we actually shape our circuitry
around that
i mean you mentioned this gets slower
and slower with age but is there
like i've i think i've uh read and
spoken
offline even on this podcast with a
developmental neurobiologist i guess
would be
the right terminology is like looking at
the very early
like from from embryonic stem cells to
like to the
to the creation of the brain and like
that's like
what that's mind-blowing how much stuff
happens there
so it's very malleable at that stage uh
it's
and then but after that at which point
does it stop being malleable
so so that's the interesting thing is
that it remains valuable your whole life
so even
when you're an old person you'll be able
to remember new faces and names you'll
be able to learn new
sorts of tasks and thank goodness
because the world is changing rapidly in
terms of technology and so on
i just sent my mother and alexa and she
you know figured out how to go in the
settings and do the thing and i was
really
really impressed by that that she was
able to do it so there are parts of the
brain that remain malleable their whole
life
the interesting part is that really your
goal is to make an internal model of the
world your goal is to say
okay the brain uh is trapped in silence
and darkness and it's trying to
understand
how the world works out there right i
love that image
yeah i guess it is yeah you forget you
forget
it's like this this lonely thing is
sitting in its own container and uh
trying to actually throw a few sensors
figure out what the hell what the hell's
going on you know what i sometimes think
about is um
the that movie the martian with matt
damon the um
it was written in a book of course but
the the movie poster shows matt damon
all alone on the red planet and i think
god that's actually what it's like
to be inside your head and my head and
anybody's head is that
you're essentially on your own planet in
there and i'm essentially on my own plan
and everyone's got their own
world where you've absorbed all of your
experiences
up to this moment in your life that made
you exactly who you are and
same for me and everyone and um
and we've got this very thin bandwidth
of communication
and i'll say something like oh yeah that
tastes
just like peaches and you'll say oh i
know what you mean
but the experience of course might be
might be vastly different for us
but anyway yes so the brain is trapped
in silence and darkness each one of us
and what it's trying to do this is the
important part is trying to make an
internal model of what's going on out
there as in how do i function in the
world
how do i how do i interact with other
people do i say something
nice or polite or do i say something
aggressive and mean do i you know all
these things that it's putting together
about the world
and i think what happens when people get
older and older
it may not be that plasticity is
diminishing it may be that their
internal model essentially
has set itself up in a way where it says
okay i've pretty much got a really good
understanding of the world now and i
don't really need to change
right so when old when when much older
people find themselves in a situation
where they need to change they can
actually are able to do it
it's just that i think this notion that
we all have that plasticity diminishes
as we grow older
is in part because the motivation isn't
there
but if you were 80 and you got fired
from your job and suddenly had to
figure out how to program a wordpress
site or something you'd figure it out
got it so the the capability the
possibility of changes
is there
you